[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 12
juillet l'engagement sera tenue dès l'an
prochain la taxe d'habitation sera
supprimé pour une partie des français à
terme 80 % des foyers seront concernés
les élus locaux s'inquiètent d'une telle
réforme nous ferons le point dans ce
journal le point également sur le
secteur des services à la personne un
secteur qui ne cesse d'embauché et qui a
pourtant du mal à recruter
c'est une problématique que l'on pensait
limitée au monde professionnel le dopage
le plusieurs cas sont recensés dans les
yvelines
les sportifs amateurs n'attire pas
l'attention des autorités
la perte est donc estimée à 10 milliards
d'euros pour les mairies la réforme de
la taxe d'habitation va rentrer en
vigueur progressivement dès l'an
prochain selon des annonces récentes du
premier ministre et du président de la
république une réforme qui inquiète les
collectivités même si le gouvernement
assure que leurs ressources seront
préservés à 100 % alors qu'en pense
justement les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines et les habitants réponse avec
ce reportage
elle la promesse sera donc tenue dès
l'an prochain une partie des français ne
paiera plus la taxe d'habitation à terme
en 2020 ce sont 80 % des contribuables
qui seront exonérés une bonne nouvelle à
première vue pour le porte-monnaie même
si les intéressés se méfie des
conséquences d'une telle réforme
il pourra d'achat en plus et c'est une
dépense en moins pour beaucoup de
beaucoup de français beaucoup de ménages
les communes elles vont trouver un autre
artifice pour récupérer cet argent de
cette façon ou alors le vent faire des
coupes sombres sur le sur les budgets de
fonctionnement et donc en l'occurrence
façon c'est une très mauvaise idée
je suis député hâtives comme tout le
monde parce que donc c'est pas mis en
marche et que vous à part ce que ça va
donner
c'est une bonne éthique pourquoi parce
que ça permet aux gens de ne pas la
payer puis ça c'est simple ça fait
partie du pouvoir d'achat quoi du côté
des élus locaux les inquiétudes sont là
nombreuses à maurepas le maire les
républicains dénoncent dans un
communiqué une mesure médiatique pour
conforter une cote de popularité dans
cette ville de 19 mille habitants la
taxe d'habitation représentent presque
5e millions d'euros de recettes par an
soit 41 % des rentrées fiscales l'an
passé un manque à gagner qui pourrait
aussi peser lourd dans l'offre de
services à saint quentin en yvelines
cité pour diminuer la dette de la france
or c'est passé du tout on fait des ont
fait certaines largesses il va falloir
que le compense ailleurs dont je dire au
bout au bout du bout vous verrez que ce
sont les contribuables qui de toute
façon seront lésés l'exécutif lui se
veut rassurant et confirme que les
ressources des collectivités seront
préservés par l'état elles les deux
partis pourront confronter leurs points
de vue sur la question lors de la
conférence des territoires prévue le 17
juillet prochain
moins de circulation et donc moins de
passage la période d'été est propice aux
travaux sur les routes comme chaque
année la collaboration de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'emploie pour
entretenir son réseau routier comme ici
à trappes
actuellement une partie de la rue gaston
on est fermée à la circulation et ce
jusqu'au lundi 17 juillet au total cet
été plus de 1 million 400 mille euros
sont investis est investi par
l'agglomération sur cinq chantiers pour
un réseau de 175 km écoutez à ce propos
régis cave kowalski membres de la
direction voirie et infrastructures pour
saint quentin en yvelines
essentiellement pour des problèmes de
circulation effectivement c'est quand
même plus compliqué de faire ça
11 septembre où
pendant les mois d'hiver alors il ya
aussi un autre paramètre qui rentre en
compte c'est aussi la météo pour
l'application des
des enrobés il faut quand même éviter
d'avoir trop de pluie sinon ça entrave
les procédés de compactage et ça permet
d'éviter également de reporter les
opérations en france plus d'un million
de professionnels travaillent dans le
secteur des services à la personne le
secteur est en plein essor et comprend
de nombreuses missions diversifiées 26
activités au total sont répertoriés par
le ministère de l'économie un marché qui
peine pourtant à recruter c'est le cas
par exemple d'une agence spécialisée
installé sur versailles qui couvre les
villes avoisinantes
reportage avec mélanie poquet
accompagnement des seniors garde
d'enfants ou encore ménage et repassage
ce sont quelques uns des services à la
personne proposés en france dans cette
agence versaillaise 19 postes en cdi
sont à pourvoir sur la base du smic
horaire
nous mutualisons
très souvent nos employés pour leur
offrir une diversité large ou pas qui
pour ne pas qu'il fasse que la mine que
du ménage et repassage ou que la garde
d'enfants mais leur pouvoir leur
permettre de faire ces deux ses deux
métiers et donc ce qui peut constituer
un tremplin
aucun diplôme particulier n'est demandée
sauf pour la garde d'enfants de moins de
3 ans pour laquelle il faut un c ap
petite enfance le français lui écrit
parlé la maîtrise du français
et puis
et puis un peu d'expérience quand même
que ce soit en ménage ou aux ménages
l'industriel par rapport à ce que l'on
peut penser ça reste un vrai métier et
donc tout le monde sait pas faire le
ménage donc c'est bien d'avoir un petit
peu d'expérience cette agence emploie
actuellement une centaine de personnes
chaque année plus de deux millions de
français font appel aux services à la
personne c'est une pratique illégale que
l'on pensait limitée au sport
professionnel le dopage dans les
yvelines il y aurait plus d'une
vingtaine de cas recensés au niveau
judiciaire chaque année un phénomène qui
pourrait toucher des milliers de
personnes en tout dans le département et
ce dans le plus grand anonymat et sans
vrai contrôle un reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et charline hurel c'est un
phénomène peu médiatisé dans le monde du
sport qui toucheraient des milliers de
personnes 5 à 15 % des athlètes amateurs
des yvelines se seraient déjà dopé une
tendance étudié par le professeur
alvarez à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
chaque année le scientifique traite
également une vingtaine de cas au niveau
judiciaire dans l'ouest parisien
oui on n'a pas des trucs tu veux plus
d'affaires dans le cyclisme
probablement mais peut-être que c'est le
hasard j'en sais rien mais aujourd'hui
on a là quelque chose qui est peut-être
plus inquiétant c'est le dopage
non pas dans le cadre de compétition
mais dans les salles de musculation sert
cole et prend les gens prennent des
dopants pour faire leur bus culation pas
forcément dans un cadre compétition pour
développer leur masse musculaire
aujourd'hui les sportifs amateurs se
fournissent directement sur internet un
danger selon le professeur c'est très
facile d'accès mais quand on l'utilisons
c'est vraiment parce qu'on prend on
al'impression comprendre la baule des
normes de la testostérone et en fait
quand on fait l'analyse peux vous
garantir que au moins la moitié des cas
on n'a pas la molécule dedans et quand
on a la bonne molécule
après on n'a pas le bon dosage nous
risquent bien entendu parce que quand on
connaît pas le dosage on peut faire une
overdose préface aidés pour lutter
contre ce phénomène le professeur
jean-claude alvarez à trouver une
solution les prélèvements capillaires
les produits dopants peuvent être
retrouvée dans les cheveux pendant
plusieurs mois alors que les tests
urinaires ne reflète que 2 à 3 jours de
consommation et le sens 24 heures font
savoir dans le dopage
il ya des substances les anabolisants
pour ne pas les citer que l'on va
prendre plus tôt avant la compétition
les prendre pendant la compétition ça
aucun intérêt ça n'apportera rien on va
les prendre avant pour développer la
masse musculaire
donc forcément pendant la compétition il
a pas on n'en retrouve pas puisque on
arrête de les prendre par contre on en a
appris pendant six mois vont donc
l'analyse capillaire va tout simplement
permettre de remonter dans le temps et
d'aller voir que la personne a pris ou
non des anabolisants en 2015 seulement
onze mille tests ont été effectués dans
toute la france au niveau amateur chaque
contrôle coûte en moyenne une centaine
d'euros hameau de sport encore avec
mardi william bertrand le jeune pilote
de 15 ans région de délais de lévis un
nom qui a été récompensé par la
fédération française du sport automobile
pour ses bons résultats en championnat
de france et a pu faire ses premiers
essais en f4 formule 4 la petite soeur
de la formule 1 sur le multi circuit du
mans pendant cinq sessions de 30 minutes
comme on peut le voir sur ces images le
produit a réalisé des tours à plus de
200 kilomètres heure et a terminé à une
seconde à peine des meilleurs pilotes du
championnat f4 2010 est un rallye
pédestre cette fois ci est
intergénérationnel était organisé il ya
quelques jours à la verrière à
l'occasion de l'inauguration du parcours
sportif du parc de la mgen un parcours
qui pouvait être fait en équipe où seul
et qu'il y était ouvert à tous osman
vendeurs d pour le reportage adulte
enfant famille à l'occasion de
l'inauguration du parcours sportif du
parc de la mgen
ils ont tous participé à un rallye
intergénérationnel le but de l'événement
permettre de créer un véritable vivre
ensemble demande qui a été pris en
compte
il ya trois ans dans les négociations
qui avaient eu pour l'ouverture du parc
en concertation avec les habitants les
habitants souhaité que justement ce beau
parc puissent bénéficier d'un petit
parcours de santé
parce que si vous voulez dans beaucoup
c'est le cas beaucoup de vide à partir
du moment où devant un parc les gens
aiment bien pratiquer une activité
physique et étant donné que la politique
sportive de la municipalité est de
développer le sport un peu partout donc
on a répondu non favorablement son
projet marche à pied course ont encore
traction petits et grands ont pu
profiter du parquet de cette animation
pour se surpasser
un événement qui permet de passer de
bons moments en famille ben c'est vrai
que c'est pas vrai c'est pas facile on
avait une petite de cinq ans dont
c'était un peu compliqué pour elle mais
même pour les adultes 1 les traction ou
voilà c'est où les abdos bon j'en
reviens un peu de temps en temps mais sa
force quand même quoi donc sert et c'est
vachement intéressant j'ai bien aimé les
abdos et
et voilà alors tout est pas le plus
compliqué alors compliqué c'était
traction et aussi sa content parce qu'il
faut se lancer donc c'est assez
compliqué d activité que les habitants
de la verrière pourront pratiquer toute
l'année
désormais le parc de la mgen est ouvert
à tous 24 heures pour créer sa
chorégraphie c'est le défi que se sont
lancé les participants d'un concours de
danse le week-end dernier à jouy en
josas l'événement réunit à des danseurs
de tous les horizons et se sont
affrontés devant un juré l'équipe de tv
fil 78 a suivi l'une des équipes sur
place dans sa progression reportage de
nicolas landry et camille lambert
[Musique]
une musique trois danseurs et 24 heures
pour créer sa chorégraphie darius alicia
et mari ne se connaissent pas n'ont pas
le même âge ni le même style de danse et
pourtant ils vont devoir faire équipe
aidés de leur coach magali imagine tu
ensemble un spectacle sur une bande-son
imposer la musique avait été bal
commence par une boîte à musique
donc là pour le coup ça a donné tout de
suite l'idée d'une boîte à musique et
puis on est parti sur ce que pouvait
faire un magicien sur une boîte à
musique
on réveille la poupée ensorcelé ce
qu'ils vivent voilà et ça se retourne
contre le magicien qui finit dans la
boîte à musique
[Musique]
on a commencé par écouter la musique
ensemble à découper et voit qu'on ne
faisait penser chaque chaque moment
moment sur ce les moments un prolibre
moment saccadé pour et au fur et à
mesure chacun portait ses idées je te
rends toi
cette petite touche est organisée par
l'association thérapie ce concours a
réuni 17 participants six équipes ont
interprété leur chorégraphie devant un
jury composé de professionnels du
spectacle
notre trio a présenté sa création un
mélange entre danse et magie
[Musique]
malgré un problème d'accessoires et de
lumière l'équipe est plutôt satisfaite
du résultat et surtout de l'expérience
un truc chouette quand même un grand
moment de rencontre de partage c'est un
très très très très cool marrant de
danser avec des niveaux différents des
est différent des disciplines
différentes
ils ont été au top malgré les malgré des
problèmes techniques sont super bien
débrouillé après je les ai vu que des
coulisses
donc je me suis pas rendu compte de face
en tout cas ils sont éclatés franchement
c'est ce qui est important
un investissement qui n'aura pas payé ce
coup ci ils sont arrivés en quatrième
position
les gagnants sont repartis avec un lot
de 500 euros darius alicia et marie
pourront retenter leur chance l'an
prochain mais cette fois peut-être pas
ensemble assez la fin de ce journal pour
nos reportages on a retrouvé en replay
sur tv et soixante dix huit points infos
sur l'application tv 78 excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]